hi I'm Devin Eric Kapadia and this
afternoon Oliver Reuben Connick and I
who both work at Wolfram will be giving
a presentation on partial differential
equations we'll speak about some
theoretical and practical aspects of
partial differential equations there'll
be oscillating drums and quantum
harmonic oscillator it should be great
fun do come along bye
so joint talk between me and Oliver
Ruben karna goes here Oliver and I both
work on differential equations but we've
got a slightly different very different
view on things I mostly work on symbolic
solutions using dissolve dyeing system
etc all our works on nd eigen system and
it's much more than that in fact he's
kind of really pushed and he solved
quite a lot in the last few years with
his work on the finite element method so
when Rob Knapp invited us to present
this talk I told myself that really
let's think of this talk in the
following way you apply to university to
study partial differential equations and
they say go take two courses one is
called partial differential equation one
which is this course and there you learn
what a PD is how it gets solved the most
common PDS you build up intuition you
build up all kinds of thing and then you
really want to try and use what you've
learnt in some substantial way and
that's when symbolic methods start
showing the limitations so my talk is on
symbolic PD's all of us speak about
numeric PD's but my example will be very
simple I'll try and give you a brief
overview of what we have on symbolic
side and if I can tell you the nine most
important theories in my eyes at this
level I think the talk would have
succeeded in its objective so that's my
plan to give you a very brief simple
introduction to symbolic pd's okay so
here is a an outline of my talk so I'll
begin with first-order PDS and I've
chosen linear and nonlinear examples to
give you a feel for what can go wrong
even in that simple case the first-order
PDS are already pretty challenging to
solve and then if you take a course on
PDS
of course you'd want to solve the
classical PD is the wave equation the
heat equation and the Laplace equation
so the second part of talk will be about
classical PDS but fortunately P DS have
gone on developing for last century so
I'll take up three modern PDS and one
have chosen are the burgers equal
from fluid dynamics the black-scholes
equation from finance and the
Schrodinger equation from quantum
mechanics which is work done by eat
either dimensional later on but these
three should give you a flavor of what's
going on in the world of PDS right now
now honestly on the symbolic side we
tend to focus on low orders but we do
have some support for higher order PD
and systems so I'll talk a little out
that and then I'll boast a level deeper
and ask how do you solve PD and that
requires solving the so called
sturm-liouville problem and so I'll talk
about a sturm-liouville problem which we
have begun to solve the last couple of
years and finally it turns out that
often you don't want the whole solution
of PD here's one of the few what you
call eigenfunctions and so I'll talk
about differential eigen systems so the
talk is going to be very simply
structured simple examples and do feel
free to ask me questions as you go along
make comments because this really is
meant to be an introduction a gentle
introduction ok so it's with first-order
PDS and my first example over there is
the transport equation which is about as
simple as things can get so the
transport equation is a linear
first-order PD it's Linnaean both the
derivatives you can see over there and
if you try and solve it the d solve then
the answer it's quite simple in fact
it's a kind of travelling wave over here
as you can see but there is an arbitrary
function of freedom over here this
confused people but really you have an
arbitrary functions freedom in the
solution of this very simple PDE so what
you can do then is to give some kind of
initial value what's called a Cauchy
problem for PDS and then you solve it
and you get back a particular solution
so there are huge family of solutions
you can pick out one with this kind of
initial value problem and finally having
done all that you do want to see the
travelling wave so you can animate it
and there's a traveling wave starts on
left Moser right
and eventually it gets to the dragging
point but it's very simple
predictable motion over here it's a
linear PD nothing can go wrong so linear
first-order P DS are on the whole rather
simple and boring but still very
important okay so now I go on to a
slightly harder kind of PD the so called
quasi linear first-order PD so that
means that you have you got a u times a
derivative over here
there's no longer linear but even if
this simple example things change
dramatically you don't have a notion of
a complete explicit solution so if you
try and solve D solve you get back a
solve object so essentially there's not
much hope of doing much with it but even
so with someone like me I know enough to
say that in some simple cases we can
actually give the initial values like
I've done over here and get back an
explicit solution but in general in the
quasi linear case you're already well
past trying to solve things explicitly
in fact things can go dramatically wrong
can have shockwaves it can have all
kinds of behavior happening even for
these scalar conservation laws okay so
that's quasi linear almost non linear
and now I want to learn in a PDS so this
is what we call a clara equation it
looks pretty difficult but in fact it's
very simple so it's x times the first
derivative over here and then y times
the first derivative over there and then
anything you like with it doesn't matter
what okay
and whatever you do over here you can
solve this in some sense so what you can
do is to find a complete integral so
these are not really general solutions
they are very special kind of solutions
so when Emperor is a long time ago
Stephen quickly pointed out that you
know you really cannot create solutions
so you see a wall you measure a we are
saying there's a nonlinear PD we are
trying to build a special solution
now the solution over here looks quite
boring
it's got a linear term in X and a linear
term in Y and almost nothing else but
then geometrically it's a two parameter
family of planes that's a lot of planes
so what you can do is you can take a one
parameter fan from there and then let it
generate a surface and that so-called
envelop is again a solution because
after all they share the same tangent
plane everywhere so here's this idea of
an envelope okay so you see that the
orange one is the plane and the blue one
is the surface which that family of
planes is enveloping so once you have a
one parameter family of planes you can
then generate a solution for this rather
difficult nonlinear PD and that's
exactly how these all work in fact I
chose this example by looking at the
implementation and that's how we solve
this initial value problem over here
okay so for nonlinear PDS we start with
complete integral build envelopes and
then we have more interesting solutions
so that's the whole story about first
order P DS but in general there's not
much hope of getting expert solutions
okay so surely the most important P DS
in the world are the wave equation the
heat equation and the Laplace equations
have spent some time on those so here's
the wave equation technically it's a
linear that's linear in the derivatives
it's second-order the second derivatives
and it's hyperbolic which means that if
you have any information then that
information are going to flow along a
certain track but it must be preserved
along the line so if you have single ID
to start then it must be preserved all
along the way so the classic example of
that is a blocked string so you leave a
a while in some banner corner a child
comes plucks it and runs away and then
what happens is the violin string goes
up and down okay so
actually this the ends known move
there's a boundary condition and then I
give it a piecewise condition because
the string got plucked let's say one
third of the way on the left and now
hand it over dissolve this is a hard
integration so it takes some time
typically we can use Fourier transform
methods Laplace transform methods
separation of variables we try all of
them in this case we opting for
separation of variables and so it's
building up a kind of Fourier series of
waves over here okay so when it's done
we will actually have a complete
solution compute a sense of complete not
let complete integral okay of the wave
equation but the pieces integration are
difficult because you really need to
take care about way on the string etc
okay so that's a solution hope it came
back okay good okay so now having done
it that's an infinite sum so you can
pull out let's see 100 terms from it and
then you let it go and here is the black
string animation but dissolve and to the
best of my knowledge this would be
pretty hard to achieve accurately with a
numerical method so it will always be
the case there will be examples which
are better suited for numerix and for
Symbolics with the numerical people of
course being far ahead of us when it
comes to any kind of practical
application okay so that's the wave
equation and now I go on to the heat
equation which is just a very opposite
so with the heat equation it's a linear
second order parabolic equation which
means that as time goes by it's going to
dissipate information you lose
information over here okay so let's take
a bar which in straight both ends and
what will happen is that eventually it
will become uniform temperature
everywhere
okay so let's the initial temperature is
given by that expression over there so
it's 20 on the left one on the right
let's see what happens
okay so solve the heat equation with
these conditions
and again it's separation of variables
that's the most useful kind of solution
over here but in this case you get back
kind of exponential decaying functions
okay so not it's not so difficult
integration but the heat equation is
certainly a very important PD okay
that's the solution the complete
solution you extract a few terms from it
then is good enough for you I think okay
each term in the solution and then you
plot the results and you see that
initially the blue line is the initial
temperature and then as time goes by it
settles down to the equilibrium
temperature of 60 degrees so that's a
nice illustration of how the heat
equation works and finally the Laplace
equation which is a class example of a
linear elliptic PD and that's something
that Oliver knows a lot more about than
I do but anyway what mean that means is
that you can specify conditions on the
boundary of a domain like a geometrical
thing on a region so I've got a
piecewise boundary condition like a unit
triangle I give it to D solve it solves
it it's not too bad over here I extract
lots of terms 300 them doesn't matter
it's pretty easy over here and then I
plot the solution and what you get back
is showing you various things it's
showing you that although the boundary
data were quite jagged the solution
itself is very very smooth and you can
see that you got a kind of saddle point
the middle so the extrema occur only on
the boundaries and at this point you say
that I have looked at maybe 30 books on
PDS
I haven't seen a single picture
illustrating this anyway and it looks
like it's time for someone write a
really good book on P DS which shows
this kind of thing in a simple way to
show that for Olympic P DS you actually
do have a kind of maximum principle
okay so that's the classical PDS and now
on to the modern PDS so my first example
is the so called burgers equation which
burgers invented to transfer D
turbulence he really want to understand
turbulence but that's the equation the
epsilon over there is a kind of
viscosity constant now if you are a
mathematician and you want to study
turbulence the last thing you want to
someone come and tell you that your
equation can be solid specifically and
per feller he really did that and even
with this piecewise condition you can
actually solve this equation completely
because guess what it reduces the heat
equation so the heat equation is enough
to solve the mighty burgers equation
okay so take some time because there's
an integration going on over there but
eventually we do get back a solution for
the burgers equation okay so there you
are and the error functions over there
are telling you it all came from the
heat equation that's an error function
over there right okay so you plot the
solution and it's the heat equation
after all so the solution is smooth but
then as we move on to the limit when
this epsilon approaches zero you do see
some kind of shock behavior coming in so
you can see over here that as epsilon
becomes very very small you actually
have a shock solution developing and in
fact the burgers equation then becomes
the scalar conservation law it's called
an inviscid burgers equation so these
have been studied for a long time by
Peter lags and people with that and they
are kind of important for real-world
applications to understand what's going
on for shockwaves etc okay so now into
the black Scholes equation which was I
think discovered around 1973 74 in a
paper black and Scholes so this is the
black Scholes equation the
parameters have got meaning in financial
terms the Sigma is volatility I think
are three different Pacific cetera and
guess what the black Scholes equation
can again be solved by reducing it to
the heat equation and in fact black and
Scholes say in the paper we make a
transformation get the heat equation and
we are done okay so that's the solution
so the main point that whether it is a
black show the equation or the burkas
equation whether it's turbulence of
finance the heat equation rules but of
course we neither understand turbulence
not advanced and finance ok so again
maybe turbulence would be good to
understand finance I'm not so sure of it
okay so having got the solution I told
myself can you actually use it for
something useful and be soared into much
useful stuff very often so yeah yeah
that's a real share price value of
option value calculated default which is
quite impressive well you can check it
with financial derivative which so your
the Sigma over your 0.7 etc the same as
what I've got over there so when you do
that you get back exactly the same
result you see all these calculators
build on the web for black Scholes
calculations and it seems to me the
expiry used to build them with
Mathematica so I think that's one area
which I would like to see people trying
out if they wish to okay
and finally the Schrodinger equations so
ETA has been doing some really good work
on this it I say give the physicist
unlike me so he actually been working on
the 2d free particle shooting the
equation okay that's the equation so you
give it some kind of simple initial
condition you give it boundary
conditions homogeneous boundary
conditions and you notice that initially
the there's a lot of uncoupling between
the two terms initial values but when
you solve it then there's some
entanglement taking place so the wave
function now becomes entangled and as
time goes by it's going to start showing
all the typical features of quantum
mechanics but to do that you need to
pass over to the
density max bond taught us that you must
go to the probably density to understand
what's happening over here so you do
that that solution times complex
conjugate and I won't burden you with
the whole calculation over here I have
an animation available X bit of time but
it's a beautiful animation which shows
the Schrodinger equation and action in
two dimensions for a quantum free
particle but the main point of is that
you do have this entangling phenomenon
taking place and it's a very nice
picture of the Schrodinger equation in
two dimensions okay so onto high order P
DS and here we don't have a lot but
still worth spending a bit of time on so
this is a beam equation it's a fourth
order PDE you give it any enough initial
conditions we try our best okay over
here and I chose the example so it works
basically but you don't get back a
solution in this case and simple
solution but my advice to you if ever
you use D solve any of what have you got
a lot of problems with them but it's
good to check the solutions correct okay
so let's do that oh yeah that's the beam
equation okay my second example is the
conduit DeVries equation which is a
popular nonlinear PDE these are become
popular in the world of solitons
okay and these have got travelling wave
solutions which were worked on by a
group at Colorado Boulder that's their
work oh yeah I can you see there are
some parameters like c1 and c2 so what
you can do is to give them some values
to get back a particular solution and
this particular solution in fact
describes a wave seen by Scott Russell
in the year 1834 so in those days there
was no cars so he was riding on
horseback he saw the way we chase it for
a mile lost in the windings of canal
came back wrote of his work no one
believed him etcetera the usual story
but today we know these solar tones are
really really important so this is the
way
of the type that Scott Russell saw on
that day in 1834 but it's a remarkable
exact solution for a highly complicated
PD so we do have some support for these
nonlinear PDEs
and finally the Cauchy Riemann equations
which are can a staple for complex
analysis so this is a system of two P DS
for the real and imaginary parts of
holomorphic function in fact there they
are an example of what's called a
hyperbolic system but they have complex
eigenvalues so when I did this work I'd
forgotten to put a check from complex
numbers in my code and that's how we can
solve them today okay so that's the
initial value problem for the Cauchy
Riemann equation but it works pretty
nicely I put some signing titles etc
over there you get back a solution you
know the solution must be harmonic
function you know that and then you can
get some really pretty pictures of the
solutions of this system using contour
plot in this case so we have some
support for high order P DS for
nonlinear PDE systems but overall saw
the shallow because that's the nature of
things they just don't have that many
solutions okay now at the very root of
these PD solution methods are the so
called sturm-liouville problems so what
happens over here you have some
differential equation like this one over
here the one little plus n it has a
parameter you do it homogeneous boundary
conditions and then you have solutions
only for a discrete set of these lambdas
the so-called eigenvalues and for a long
time you just give back zero solution
people complain a lot but we just need
to have a language to express these
solutions but we do now so this gives
back the complete set of eigenvalues for
this sturm-liouville problem okay so you
can make
a list of the eigenvalues or you can go
ahead and plot them and it all works
just fine now the delicious a problem
means that you got 0 at both the ends
over here right and if you now go into
what's called the norman problem where
you have the derivative 0 at both the
sides then you still get back a solution
and you can again make a table you can
plot it but this time you get cosines as
the eigenfunctions because that's the
derivative condition things quickly get
difficult in fact that's what stopped us
from progressing over here so when you
come to the so called robin condition
where you have a linear combination on
the left interval or the interval and
another condition over here then you
know how you can solve the eigenvalue
equation in closed form so things start
going quite really wrong over here
because you get back this translate
equation to solve so typical textbook
will have something like tangent of
lambda equal to lambda as a basic
example in this area so let's try and
locate the roots of this equation and
you see that between let's say 1 and 10
you have a root near 4 and you have a
root near 7 something and what you can
do is you can tell B solve that I don't
want all the solutions over here I just
want the solutions that lie between 1
and 10 using assumptions in fact that's
why we have the assumptions option and D
solve and you get back this these kind
of pretty difficult looking root objects
and they're meant to be friendly okay
although people don't let me feel that
way but this over here is an approximate
value for root that's another
approximate value for another root and
these are exact objects and they are so
exact that you can evaluate them let's
say to 10,000 decimal places like oh
here they are
10,000 decimal places so the real
problem is how do you make them more
pleasant and you
bill for users and that's what we're
trying to at the moment to try and make
these root objects kind of presentable
in a nicer way okay so now I go on to
the last topic which is differential
icon systems so often you don't want the
whole solution be sore you just want a
few solution that's good enough you
don't want the whole set of solutions so
that's what the adding system does
Oliver worked on any item system I
borrowed a design and a digan system is
you just get back the first four
eigenvalues and the first flagon
functions for the laplacian operator
with the restate conditions on the
interval 0 to pi and again can plot them
and then it I did some good work on this
problem so he worked with the quantum
harmonic oscillator which is pretty
difficult problem and he worked out the
eigenvalues and eigenfunctions so what
you see over here are the ladder of
eigenvalues for the quantum harmonic
oscillator you go up the ladder over
here ok and once again you want to
breathe life into the eigenfunctions so
you put some time component and then you
build a providentially function and
finally I won't really evaluate the plot
but I'll show you the animation itself
in final form but this is a remarkable
animation which shows the power of
Mathematica for this kind of computation
but I haven't seen this kind of thing in
any textbook or any other place okay now
it's very nice when I can do something
for these all it's even nicer than some
Erlich etai or somewhere else can come
and do something with that functionally
the quantum mechanics applications and
even nicer when some user in the wild so
to speak righteous saying you now have
done a nice application so a couple of
weeks ago John Snyder who is a longtime
user of Mathematica and in fact a
retired actuary wrote to me saying you
know I have worked
the vibrations of a circular drum with
the iron system the whole story is a bit
more complicated but basically he was
trying to tell me that if you take a
drum and he strike it on the middle
that's not very interesting he strike on
the side just to be a Hitler that let go
that's a hard problem to solve and he's
done it okay so we had some email
exchange he did most of work over here
so this really is John Snyder's work so
you take the laplacian you are on a disk
you work out the eigen values and eigen
functions people know about this know
that they are Bessel zeros and Bessel
functions and then here are the eigen
functions I realized I was a kind of bug
and dissolve in the egg system which was
giving branch cuts for these eigen
functions I fixed that and then John
took it from there and he used the first
120 writing functions to build this
animation of a circular drum edge so
that's my final example and it really
shows the power of awesome bollocks
the power of our visualization etc so
let's let D and in-system play the drum
as a final example so this is the
circular drum head with an impulsive it
at one third of the way to the boundary
and it's pretty remarkable you can do so
many term calculations with our symbolic
functions so that really is it for me
and what does the future hold well in
the future we want to have more integral
transform methods and we realize there's
a limit to what you can do with exact
solutions so we won't blue system of PDS
but you want approximate solutions of
these systems so in some future release
I don't promise when we will have large
system of PD is done with XA series
solutions or the kind of solutions so
that's the plan for dissolve in
the near future okay so but those
remarks I'll stop for you and if there
any question let's find the red hand
over to Oliver thank you very much all
right so I'll I'll continue actually
there's a lie on the slide
my name is not Oliver I'm n Devendra
okay now jokes aside my name is Oliver
and I work in the numerix Department so
I basically work on everything that is
numerix and finite element related so we
use the finite element method to solve
PD es and other things over regions so
basically if you use any salt with the
finite element method or in the eigen
system or interpolating functions over
regions or maybe in an integrate with
the planet element method specific I
specified
that's things I work on now and this
always been around in Mathematica for
quite a while and there's been a lot of
stuff being put into n dissolve for
which I cannot take take claim but I
quickly wanted to point out that there's
really a lot of other stuff so any solve
is able to solve ordinary differential
equations boundary value type of
equations delay differential equation
differential equations hybrid and
discontinuous equations differential
algebraic equations and there's partial
differential equations and in those
there's the ones with rectangular
regions and then there's arbitrary
regions so the thing I'm working on is
the last point the arbitrary regions for
n useful for partial differential
equations and this is basically what my
talk is going to be about I'll focus a
little bit on boundary conditions in
this talk because I feel that's
something that I'd like to explain a bit
a bit better and there were some some
new development so okay if you want to
solve P DS what do you need you need
three things you need the PDE you need a
region and some kind of a boundary
condition then you solve the PDE and
then you have a visualization or like a
post processing step step typically
that's some kind of a visualization how
does it observe
yeah salt post passing process so if we
look at the PDE actually I'm only
concerned with a single PDE and that's
the P DS you see here that's something
called coefficient form so it has a
second order time derivative first order
time derivative give grant so basically
this shows all type of derivatives in
space up to second order and derivatives
of time also up to second order so I'm
saying I'm only concerned with this
specific PDE but if you look at it a
little closer you see in blue
highlighted specific PDE s that you
might be familiar with for example the
first one is the Laplace equation so
grayed out all the terms that are not
active in this specific part to to
represent a Laplace equation if we have
a Poisson equation we get another an F
on the right hand side
Hummels type equation convection
diffusion reaction equations so you see
in this coefficient form all these
classical PDE s are embedded so that's
basically I'm concerned with this
coefficient form of this PD and that's
what I'm trying to solve this is the
only PD I'm really concerned with okay
how do you use that so typically in the
setup you specify some kind of region
you'd say okay the region is a disk you
have an operator a portion minus one so
this is type of a type of equation and
then you specify some kind of a boundary
condition this case I've chosen a
dirichlet condition and say that the
dependent variable U is supposed to be
zero everywhere where X is larger than
zero on this on this region you then
call nd salt value or nd solve same
thing just a little bit of a different
output with the specifications I've just
given and then you use plot 3d for
example to visualize the solution that's
what nd solve is is capable of solving
over this specific disk this is just to
give you an overview of what the
workflow typically looks like so and
that's then the visualization of the
solution now
boundary conditions for the finite
element method that we have is currently
three so we can specify directly
conditions that specifies
cific value on the boundary where you
want to apply the daily condition we can
specify a Norman value that specifies a
flux over an edge on the boundary and
I'm going to explain that in a little
more detail just now and then newly
added we have periodic boundary
conditions and arbitrary boundary shaped
boundary shapes so and I'm also going to
show a few examples of that so here are
the Derrick's lake condition and the
norman value where could you apply them
so in in blue you see positions where
you could apply the daily condition so
it could be outside of a region it could
be in an inner hole or it could even be
at a material boundary so that's another
place where you could apply directly
conditions the norman value is typically
either at an inner region like an in a
hole or something like that or an outer
edge these boundary conditions are
specified by two arguments the directly
condition sees the dependent variable
equals to something the value you want
to specify and the predicate where that
there's the condition is supposed to
apply the norman value is quite similar
it gets a value of this type G minus Q
type the dependent variable and
predicate word that's supposed to be
true I'm going to talk about where that
specific form of the Norman value comes
about just now so what I'm going to try
now is I'm going to try to explain the
finite element method in 1/2 a slide so
it's it's not it's not completely insane
just a bit so basically what you have so
remember we had this coefficient form in
the beginning so the finite element
method works by taking this coefficient
form plugging it into an integral and
multiplying it with something called the
test function Phi that's basically what
I've done in the first first row this
coefficient form is blocked in this
integral x 5 and set to zero so the
finite element method tries to find a
solution to a PDE in a weak sense so
it's not trying to find the exact
solution but a weak solution so what you
do then you take this this grief
formulation and Phi is completely
unspecified we don't know what Phi is
and it doesn't matter for now actually
we integrate this thing by parts and
there you see
you get an integral over the domain and
an integral over the boundary condition
or some integral over the boundary that
has a normal vector in it so that's end
time dot C na blah blah blah blah and
this specific integral or the content of
this integral is what is replaced with
anointment value when you specify
anointment value you replace this part
of the integral that is exactly that is
what's happening internally I never ever
compute actually the normal normal value
I just replaced the contents of this
integral that's what mathematically is
happening when you apply anointment
value okay here's an example for small
type of equation we have minus C naught
value I specify some arbitrary region
here I have the laplacian operator minus
20 I said the directly conditioned on
some part of the boundary condition and
now I'd like to specify anointment value
n where the normal is n type dot C now
that u equals minus 2 u whatever that
means it doesn't really matter now what
internally happens is so I spent this
this value minus 2 u is you'll put that
into the normal value and that is
actually then internally replacing the
integral the boundary integral we had
from the derivation earlier and then you
get the solution like depicted below so
the boundary condition condition is in
the upper left-hand part where it's put
down to a specific value and on the
inner circle we have a specified flux of
minus 2 times the dependent variable ok
the special the the special thing about
this is also that this is actually on an
arbitrary shaped region and it has a
hole so that's something and you solve
only learned to do at about version 10
yeah you have a question
[Music]
and the question is whether you have
control over the test functions not
directly you could if you wanted to but
that would involve your own programming
the test functions we currently use are
so-called certain deputy functions if
your if you are into the Pantanal word
so there's certain deputy type of test
functions maybe we could talk about this
a little a little later it's going out
of the region
yeah it's yes exactly and that's a very
good one thing I forgot to mention so
note that actually the content of - seen
nabla you the laplacian isn't just
exactly the negative term of what is in
the norman value
you never specify this see in the norman
value because you only need to specify
the right hand side this Norman value is
tightly tightly coupled to the equation
you are actually trying to solve okay
yeah they are all function of the
spatial variable of time okay they can
be off time they cannot be yet dependent
of the dependent variable itself
they cannot yet be nonlinear so to speak
yeah okay but okay periodic boundary
conditions that's a new boundary
condition we introduced in version 11
what that does you specify a predicate
where the boundary condition is supposed
to be where you want periodicity then
you specify no sorry you first specify a
relation of how the function the
dependent variable is supposed to relate
to another part on the boundary so you
want to say you just want the at the
bottom example I have a periodic
boundary condition and I want the
dependent variable U and I want that at
the outer circle which is the blue one
in the law in the picture below I want
that is the the target region so what
happens
with the second function that map's the
points on the blue region on to the
green region I evaluate the dependent
variable U and those values are actually
used than in the solution so this is a
somewhat the mechanism is somewhat
complicated but if you get used to it I
think it makes it make sense so in this
case I have a cut out region I have a
Derrek Lee condition on the upper and
the lower edge of these boundaries and I
have a periodic boundary condition that
takes the value off the green side and
puts it to the blue side and if you look
at the solution so here's the solution
then the left-hand side has this red
spot and the corner or the outer edge of
that spot is reflected onto the inner
side there so that's how the periodicity
works now one thing is what I've shown
here is so these edges are they look
exactly the same so they're just a
direct mapping but that's not
necessarily you don't have to do that
they can be deformed or anything like
that you just if you have a projection
from one side to the other to the other
you can actually you're quite flexible
of what you can you can project okay
that works in 3d as well just so same
thing so laplacian equals to one port
type of equation on a cube we have a DHT
condition which says the up the side
parts of of that cube are held fixed at
this at zero and we take the values from
it have a look from so a yeah right
thank you
whatever you mapped the points from the
X 0 on the right hands to the right hand
side and those are made equal then so
there is a periodicity there okay next
I'd like to talk a bit about boundary
conditions for wave type of equations
one thing I'd like to
to mention is a second order time
derivative of our higher order time
derivative equations can be reformulated
into systems of first order equations
and that's going to be important in a
second so if you now specify a second
wave equation second order time
derivative second order spatial
derivative have some initial condition
I've used an error function type of
thing and write and you use you solve
that with nd solve and we'll use the
finite element that's something that's
how that would behave so you the wave
spreads out and it comes back from the
edges so it's a reflecting boundary that
you have but what you might want to have
you might want to have an absorbing
boundary condition what I'm going to try
to show you now is how that is actually
modeled so so in order to model this
absorbing boundary condition I used
exactly the same equation I had before
this reflecting boundary condition but
now I specify a Norman value on the
temporal derivative of the time dip of
other of you what does it mean if we
remember from earlier we had a second
order time derivative replaced as two
equations first order equations so that
means this Norman value is working on
the auxiliary variable in this
reformulated equation and if we do that
and use this absorbing type of model
then the wave equation starts to look
like that and the wave is actually
absorbed in the boundaries and this
stuff this is just a 1d example but you
can do this in two and 3d this is just
to show how you'd model absorbing
boundary conditions and now oops there
was a step too far so and now because we
have the periodic boundary condition we
can now also have a wave travel
out of one side of the region and back
into the other side of the region what
I've done now I've changed the initial
condition sorry the initial condition
stays the same however I use a
derivative of the initial condition and
to give it an initial velocity the way
we the wave has an initial velocity now
and if we use that then you'll see that
the wave travels out of one side and
back into the other side so this
combination of using a derivative on the
temporal variable and periodic boundary
conditions allows you to now model a
travelling wave out of the periodic
region going out one end and re-entering
at the other end another end okay so
that's that's that one other thing I
wanted to show that I thought is maybe a
little bit didn't that I'd like to
promote a little more it's actually one
thing you can do with nd solve and the
finite element method that you cannot do
in two best to the best of my knowledge
and any other tool is like Interactive
PDE solving so I have a Laplace equation
here upon some type of equation here and
I have a rectangle inside that region
and if I now touch this this corner
point it uses a very coarse grid and I
can actually move about and actually
interactive see how the solution is
solved how this equation is solved and
as soon as I release it the mesh is
refined and a proper solution is
computed I thought that's that's a neat
thing to show because I don't think
there's many other tools that actually
allow you interactive real-time PDE
solving okay so now we're doing nd eigen
system so same thing like the vendor did
just in the merits and arbitrary regions
and again the only equation I'm
concerned about is up there is still
again this coefficient form the only
difference now is that I'm trying to
solve not for F equals F but lambda U so
an eigenvalue problem again I need a PDE
the region and I need some boundary
conditions possibly I don't necessarily
need them for organ systems but you can
specify them first example and the eigen
system laplacian a negative laplacian U
is independent variable from 0 to PI and
I want for AG inverse and eigen
functions those are the eigen values I
showed there and there's a plot of the
eigen functions okay next example do we
add a boundary condition so this is a
constraint eigen value and the
constraint is on the left hand side x
equals 0 we set the dependent variable 2
to 0 and then we get slightly different
eigen values and the eigen modes also
look a little bit different we can now
also solve periodic I can value problems
in this case I have a portion and this
is kind of a so it so surely our type
equation with an asymmetric potential
the periodic boundary condition uses the
dependent variable U goes from x equals
to PI and get the solution from minus 2
pi upon the position at minus 2 pi and
that is the solution for this asymmetric
potential now what we can do is we can
also solve anti periodic boundary
conditions
and now say for example the green line
on the right hand side is added as what
0.5 roughly and if we follow that should
be by I don't see it actually maybe the
blue one is a bit better so the blue one
starts at 0.1 1.5 on the left-hand side
and goes to 0.15 on the right-hand side
so that's an anti periodic boundary
condition we could also have multiples
of that like we wanted to times of U and
again the plot changes a bit so this is
a way how you can influence how the
dependent variable is supposed to behave
on the periodic boundary condition yeah
okay and the eigen system of course
works in two and three D what we have
here is an image mesh of a salt on the
Salt Lake and something like Stephen
showed in his talk basically it computes
the eigen functions of the salt lake if
you have a Derrek Lee condition set to
zero or on the all-around on the
boundary one other thing I'd like to
talk about that is not yet available
this is going to be available in 11.1
that's the automatic grouping of
boundaries so I have a somewhat
complicated two numerical region there
and I generate a boundary element mesh
that's what it looks like the wireframe
of that what now happened internally is
that the element mesh actually computes
the normals of each of these edges and
groups them together by normals so you
see I have five or six boundary element
Marcus one two three four five six and
I've colored the boundary mesh according
to the groups it has found now why would
that be important
I can now actually say I'd like to use
markers 2 & 4 for example which I've
found and I can plot them so I see this
is the inner side and the outer side of
the boundary and I can actually use
these selections to specify directly
boundary conditions so what you see here
now and it's low oops and it's lower
part I've used this selection here as a
book as a predicate in the directly
condition and specified use that to
solve the PDE okay
this works for complicated geometries as
well so if you have a crankshaft or
something like that there's no way
you're going to specify XYZ is this and
that and whatnot this will automatically
automatically group the boundaries for
you so you can then call nd solve
specify the boundary condition and say
at this specific example that specific
marker I'd like to that have that
boundary condition okay I did lie a bit
in the beginning when I said I'm just in
a little bit
so I said I'm only concerned with one PD
it's true it's only one PD but you can
couple them so you can now have this is
an example of two PD es it's in U and V
in this case are the dependent variables
the equations get a bit longer and note
that in the first equation we have c1
one nabla you see one to nab Lavie and
then the second equation we have c2 1 w
and c2 to nab la vie these are all
possible cross couplings between the
equations so anything you'd like to
model there is no limit in how you can
cross couple between these equations
directly conditions can be cross coupled
and the normal values can also be cross
coupled what can you do with that
for example structural mechanics in 3d
I've I've in the notebook there's a
small definition of a stress operator
that's not not really important how that
actually looks like it's basically a set
of nine laplace couplings that's what
try to show there and what I have now I
have what I'd like to do is I'd like to
compute the structural eigenmodes of a
clarinet so if you if you were to sprite
declare and how would the clarinet
actually resonate I generate a mesh and
that mesh now has actually inserted
these boundary groups that I've shown
earlier into that mesh so there's
different parts on the boundary that
have different different groups and I
can now for example use something like a
manipulate to actually scan through
these these boundaries so you see
different parts are actually highlighted
no and if I if I open it up I actually
show this is the marker number 22 edge
20 to 25 and that with that mechanism
you can actually go through your
geometry find that the regions you're
interested in and then use that
well it's rendering I think no we're too
far
that's one okay there we go so was
running a bit what I've done now is I've
used this clarinet example and specified
three selections on the geometry I said
the mouthpiece is is not to move and
then to circular parts which I've marked
and red on the on the final examples as
well are held fixed and I've computed
and set there is those vibrational
eigenmodes to zero there's no movement
in X Y or Z direction and I've computed
what twenty of these arguments have just
displayed a couple of them that looked
somewhat somewhat interesting so just to
make it clear this is not how the how
the how the clarinet sounds it's just if
you were to use the clarinet and hit it
with a stick or something like that and
hold it that's how it would move
resonates or something like that okay
and that's the end of the talk and this
off and dissolve rock so what we can do
is we can solve complex valued variable
coefficient P DS I didn't show all of
these things here we can have events in
these PV es as well transient stationary
I can system analysis orbit arbitrary
regions one two three dimensions in
parallel yeah and if you have questions
my email is Reuben Coe at Wolfram comm
it's not a secret if you work on PDS and
stuff like that send me an email
you're more than welcome to do that
thank you for your attention
you